paola madonna stai calmo ma perché mi
chi è partito come se dovesse spuntare
mi di gesù
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video
sono fa vigente oggi siamo su one that
che è un gioco horror se non nel caso
non avesse notato è giorgio può andare
solo su start game le altre cose ci sono
ma non le puoi cliccare ci sono per
bellezza provo grazie per averle messe
ugualmente e ci sono cose violente che
bello dovete preso sta la camicia 0 da
zara 9 stand cos'è ma ero già vestito mi
sto svestendo ma mi sono solo alzato
perfetti ma è tutto così sto gioco posso
anche muovermi presse space to stand
dato o perfetto un'ora e mezza
c'è questo qua c'è la cia le movenze di
mia nonna perfetto che è meglio vado ai
due allora ragazzi però è già qualcosa e
ripongo molta fiducia in questo
videogame soprattutto perché ci sono dei
quadri con delle galline che è la casa
di banderas che c'ha il quadro di rosita
ma ecco un piccione cioè adesso cambiamo
animale sentite marche che so fare e di
preciso e uscire questa porta riuscita
non si può fare in sostanza che cosa
rappresenta
[Musica]
salve non è il classico antica mette un
paio d'occhiali per cortesia scolata zia
capiamoci io fa vj lei rosita tutti e
due siamo pacifici è quindi calma ci
vuole calma è diventato tutto buio bella
ii disse allora madonna
salve ma che belle potere che delle
posate che abbiamo qui sul tavolo
signora zia e lo so che sono in gioco e
quindi devi avere questa impressione
tipo è lo so lo so lo so finito tutti
calmi tutti calmi c'è un terremoto o
terre ma un apposito siamo stati cinque
minuti da quando gioco non capito ancora
un cazzo samara 6 tour dopo tutto sto
bordello devo di sedermi o mi fai fare
che cosa col televisore lg miglior
marchio già s'è rotto a vangol
hanno rotto così droga ma si droga forte
ma cos'è a salve e buongiorno giardino
senta e mi porta un bicchier d'acqua
invece non è che ho chiesta avere un
bicchier d'acqua
no quella è quello il mobile l'acqua si
trova in cucina che sta dietro di te no
no no no non è sotto il divano la cucina
sta dietro il consegue ancora roja ci
avrei scommesso che prima o poi sarebbe
successo fantastico io volevo un
bicchiere d'acqua e bat che sono in
macchina
quindi stiamo andando in macchina mi
sono schiantato contro una cosa che mi è
cascata su una macchina che abusa di
culo a voce la fanta gratis almeno
quello premi e per usare lo switch è un
supermarket sta roba non centrare in mai
ma neanche se mi schianta sigla macchina
una serie a questo è un motel che era
spento sono la accendevo io stata
scattata una scala ma come io mi sono
schiantato mentre andavo in macchina ma
eravamo dentro un modello come cazzo hai
fatto entrare in un motel senza accorge
prima 6 deficiente permesso o un entrata
così non la vedevo da dai tempi di al
trust ragazzi tra l'altro deve uscire
due quindi tranquilli che non trovò
c'abbiamo nel culo tutti quanti wanted
usa ma chi ti chiami usa ma chi e se
ricercato e minchia questo nome
qualcosa sta bloccando questa porta del
pezzo ne frega a me io so cosa ma chi ha
un obiettivo trova lisa casa elisa non
perfette sono passato ragazzi che ci
dovrebbe essere un cadavere o troppo
piede di porco fantastico mi spiegate
perchè un cadavere dovrebbe essere
vicino ad un motel e perché io ancora
non me la sono data a gambe qualcuno ha
idea è di tornare alla porta che prima
era bloccato che perfetto cazzo che
cos'è qualcosa uscendo i cadaveri dei
bambini e delle persone che corrono a
caso ma entriamo c nel modello certo è
sentito zuma che gli aironi entriamo il
piede di porco si è rotto mentre tentava
di entrare fantastico non posso
andarmene senza mia figlia
quindi se tua figlia qua dentro bravo i
[ __ ] a mandarla in posti così tutto
più tutto ciò intendo presto ho capito
stai calmo certo che tua figlia propone
bello suo quadro nei posti più belli la
devi mandare sicuro un deficiente ma di
proporzioni bibliche cazzo stai permesso
no cost a salve figlia che poi non
capire lisa si chiama la figlia che sono
mare figlia sei qui è bello succede
credibile
mia figlia quando è entrata va dentro
non visto i quadri non è scappata a
gambe levate proprio sono aperti
condotti non so se io però io mi resi
subito dei [ __ ] mago subito avanti
apro io qualcosa sta bloccando la porta
dall'altra parte c'è uno che bussa la
defi cente sono io che dovrei bussare
non lui che cazzo bus a lui il miglior
non ci sono in difficile o una chiave
comica vista posso entrare condotto no
perché ci sarà qualcuno nel condotto
magari c'è mia figlia c'è qualcuno che
bussa alle porte c'è qualcun altro posso
andarci ma sì che ci possa andare de
voce del sangue per terra promette bene
il suo boss non è che posso chiamare la
polizia ce l'avrei un cellulare no non
chiamiamo la polizia andiamo noi merda
qui è tutto chiuso security room la
stanza di sicurezza che belo c'è bisogno
di una chiave per entrare ci mancava
solo quello che posso andare nella
stanza di sopra quindi a quel punto
apriamo la stanza guadagnava è questa
qua era vero
perfetto permesso c'è un pianoforte
l'unica roba rimasta intatta visto
videogame e il pianoforte fantastico
cosa devo fare qua dentro c'è un'altra
chiave
penso che corre e senta lei che le piace
corner e non si corre nei corridoi
l'ho sempre detto io c'è qualcuno ma che
chi corre da un'ora e mezza è chiusa
dalla tua parte sei un deficiente la
puoi aprire quando vuoi st porta basta
che niente capisce non capirono
efficienti sarà una porta che si apre è
perfetto [ __ ] non tuono picchia ci
mancava solo belli stigma sempre più
belli quadri che fuori c'è il suo aero
posto mi dà noia
mia figlia è una [ __ ] c'è un coso qui
però preso perfetto io sto andando
avanti a stanza dopo stanza a prendere
oggetti che mi fanno andare alla stanza
successiva ad ora i videogame così giuro
io c'è un cacciavite comunque potrei
darteli in testa volendo possa aprire la
porta ma niente qualcosa bloccare cosa
cazzo mi serve un cacciavite o aperta mi
chiama che ci ha passato con mammut
incredibile ho permesso
c'è un'altra porta a caso figlia figlia
se qui dentro via
non credo sia mia figlia però è comunque
senti questa chiave mi serve per aprire
la stanza di sotto grazie sei ben
sicuramente un figlio tanto deve
succedere qualcosa sono convinto se deve
succedere qualcosa che succede in fretta
non mi rompete le palle
spunta ti prego se di spunta armi
qualcosa in faccia a farlo adesso non è
stato
tumori sta la famiglia ho parlato nel
momento preciso è sempre stars
incredibile voglia di parlare quando non
devo parlare qualcuno [ __ ] lo
sapevo che non uscirà qualcosa di certo
stronzo di merda cosa io sapevo
dall'inizio sapevo che sarebbe uscito un
cristiano a correre bravo complimenti ma
voi un momento giusto è domandato ma ma
ma è che cazzo me ne deve fregare dove
andava bene a sto punto che ha aperto la
porta vediamo che c'è dentro la che non
lo so
bello opprime il gra grande 6 pulire to
un'altra porta chiusa ci mancava solo
quello ho preso la testa la ragazza
quindi devo poter entrare qua dentro per
forza non c'è elettricità e all'aris
trans hamas questa porta eccolo minchia
che ne so io al beni servirebbe questo
scotch
così almeno giochiamo la facciamo una
challenge quella che ci strappiamo i
peli tiva devo risolvere il problema che
in teoria io dovrei morire folgorato
subito all'istante però con dello scotch
in teoria dovrei riuscirci sono morto
sarebbe stato troppo figo ok bene si è
aperta la cras cosa aveva security
ronfate mi uscì tanto lo so che non ci
arrivo senza che i miei salti addosso
qualcosa ma vabbè gola macro discorso
vai vai vai vai bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye veloce veloce veloce veloce
veloce veloce prima che quel tizio
arrivi tanto quando ci arrivato ancora
nessuno è perfetto
entra
dio mio ok il nuovo obiettivo non l'ho
fatto in tempo a leggere come chiudi
qual è il nuovo obiettivo che non ho
capito cos'è alle telecamere di solver
niara posso vedere che cosa succede
fantastico
c'è una porta dei nani che succede cosa
sta succedendo
un giorno c'è una porta bassa lì ci
sbatte la testa se proprio lo sapevo lo
sapevo che mi sta allontanando apposta
perché lo sapevo possiamo finire di
guardare ste cose grazie molto gentile
che cazzo ne è servito
non ho capito cosa cosa sto facendo gli
ancora qua dentro dov'è mia figlia non
c'è non c'è tua figlia sei contento non
si chiude la porta a portà davanti alla
porta avanti ma potranno [ __ ] tua madre
che l'ha fatta è che ora i ragazzi
concluso qui l'episodio di oggi perché
poi diventa un po più incasinato di
quello che avete visto però è figo per
essere un in dior non si può che non mi
capitavano indie così figli quindi
ragazzi se il video è piaciuto come
solito lasciato un momento questo mi
pare che sia un mi piace anche a pagine
di facebook e come ogni video trovate
nello script non si discute ci vediamo
lì e ricordatevi che se una figlia entra
in un hotel del cazzo piuttosto fatevi i
cazzi vostri è andata al cinema questa è
per concludere alliance